hi Leute und Willkommen zu vlogmas Tag
11 wir brauchen vom Schnitt jetzt mal
ein bisschen Pause deswegen habe ich mir
einen Kommentar zu Herzen genommen von
euch und zwar meinte jemand vielleicht
machst du auch einfach mal ein oneaker
wo Du einfach mal erzählst und redest
und wo es nicht so viel zum Schneiden
gibt und ich glaube Timo kann jetzt mal
nach zwei Tagen Skifahren auch so ein
bisschen Pause gebrauchen und dass wir
uns vielleicht auch einfach mal einen
Abend zu zweit nehmen die letzten Tage
sah es nämlich so aus dass jeden Abend
Timo geschnitten hat wir haben tagsüber
was gemacht und entweder hat er am Abend
schon geschnitten oder er ist um 7 Uhr
oder 6:30 Uhr aufgewacht und hat das
dann versucht bis so 12:30 Uhr ungefähr
fertig zu schneiden ursprünglich dachte
ich mal hey wir machen das so wir drehen
am Tag ungefähr so bis 16 17 Uhr wenn es
dann halt irgendwann dunkel wird und am
nächsten Tag schneidet Timo ungefähr von
ja von 8 bis 11 und dann laden wir es
hoch und Easy Peasy aber natürlich mit
PL wie es immer so ist ja hat's einfach
nicht so hingehauen und man hat ja auch
einfach jetzt gerade so ein Leben also
das was wir ja gerade tun hat ja nichts
mit echtten Leben zu tun wir sind ja
völlig Buff einfach von allem was wir
hier gerade erleben ich meine ich sitze
neben einem Kamin ja timo hat mir gerade
Anweisung gegeben und er wird jetzt
schon wieder irgendwas hier
reinschneiden also erzähle ich euch
gleich mal richtig schön ordentlich
übers Skifahren und was mir beim
skifahrn besonders wichtig ist ist die
Sicherheit genauso wie bei meiner
handyhölle und jetzt kommt kurz Werbung
casy F bietet dir den perfekten Schutz
für dein Handy ohne dass du auf ein
stylisches Äußeres verzichten musst und
durch die große Auswahl bei cas F ist
einfach für jeden was dabei und man kann
sein Handy für jeden Anlass passend
stylen ich habe gesehen dass sie
weihnachtliche Hüllen haben und ich sag
mal so so eine winterliche
weihnachtliche Hülle steht bei mir auf
jeden Fall schon mal auf dem
Wunschzettel Timo du schenkst mir dann
so eine Hülle ne ja da oben ist der
Weihnachtsmann lieber guter
Weihnachtsmann schenkst du mir eine
Hülle so gut wie du gefahren bist auf
jeden Fall er sagt so gut wie ich
gefahren bin schenkt er mir auf jeden
Fall eine aber ich möchte auch das cute
christmas Charm das kriege ich auch
danke schaut einfach gerne mal bei
cassifi vorbei und mit meinem Code malw
Z bekommt ihr noch 10% Rabatt oh oh da
fliegen die Sticker
Timo ich
glaube schnell komm her die Sticker
müssen runter die
brennen die sind so
heiß zum Glück habe ich es
gesehen hast du noch irgendwo was drauf
geklebt ne so gut reagiert gut reagiert
heute habe ich auf jeden Fall eine gute
Reaktion Sicherheit ist auch wichtig
wenn ihr versucht euer Bild einzurichten
und vielleicht bist ihr auch gerade auf
der Suche nach einem Weihnachtsgeschenk
oder wünscht dir von jemandem was da ist
bei casy FI auf jeden Fall für alle was
dabei es lohnt sich vielleicht auch auf
meinem Instagram Account vorbeizuschauen
dort gibt es nämlich ein kleines
Gewinnspiel und mega coole Fotos von mir
auf einem
Berg es wird richtig warm hinter mir ich
komme ein bisschen näher ran aber
ansonsten läuft blogm voll gut ich kann
mich da nur bei Timo bedanken weil ja
durch seine harte Arbeit kann man
einfach nur so sagen durch seine harte
Arbeit oh mein Gott jetzt chill mal ganz
kurz kann mir vorstellen dass wir das
dieses J wirklich bis Weihnachten
schaffen was extrem cool wäre weil ich
das jetzt glaube ich schon seit 5 Jahren
versuche 6 Jahren versuche vlogmas
durchzuziehen weiß nicht was ich mir
gedacht habe bei dieser Frisur also ich
bin einfach Legolas und ansonsten würde
ich gerne vom Skifahren erzählen also
wir sind heute wieder mal Ski gefahren
und ich hatte schon Angst und ich hatte
auch überlegt gar nicht noch mal zu
fahren weil ich mir dachte hey komm ich
habe das jetzt das letzte mal irgendwie
gepackt warum muss ich mein Glück
herausfordern wenn ihr mich schon länger
kennt dann wisst ihr auch dass ich
Panikattacken und sowas hatte und Angst
ist einfach ein Thema bei mir in meinem
Leben das das ist einfach ständig
präsent und ja da hatte ich eigentlich
gar nicht so Bock drauf aber weil ich
Timo natürlich auch irgendwie nicht
enttäuschen wollte dachte ich gut dann
fahren wir heute auch noch mal und dann
hatten wir das Problem dass diese Piste
in auf der ich gestern geübt habe
gesperrt war also die war noch nicht
vorbereitet die war noch nicht ready da
hat's glaube ich einfach viel geschneit
und ja deswegen mussten wir auf eine
andere von der Timo eigentlich sicher
war dass die ein bisschen zu schwer ist
es war immer noch so eine blaue Piste
also eine einfache Piste und trotzdem
gab es da so ein paar Passagen die wohl
nicht so einfach waren na ja und dann
sind wir dann da hochgefahren und dieses
Mal das erste Mal ohne Skilehrer einfach
drauf los und ich muss aber sagen durch
Timo hatte ich dann doch einen guten
skilhrer ja aber es hat halt es hat
geklappt es war aber schon sehr langs
also ich war sehr langsam ich war sehr
vorsichtig ich bin paar mal hingefallen
dann gab es manchmal so Windböhen dass
uns der Schnee so ins Gesicht gepeitscht
ist und das war schon ja das war schon
sehr aufregend alles und schwierig und
danach haben wir uns erstmal hingechillt
haben kurz was getrunken haben mal alle
hier ne die Pferde wieder in den Stall
geparkt alle alle beruhigen sich jetzt
hier mal und dann hatten wir Glück weil
dann wurde die andere Piste aufgemacht
bei der ich gestern geübt habe aber die
kam mir gestern halt auch schon extrem
schwer vor na ja und dann bin ich halt
mit Timo diese Piste entlang und es ging
halt voll gut aber nicht nur so hey ich
war schon ein bisschen besser ich war um
tausend mal besser als gestern es hat
sich richtig angefühlt als ob in meinem
Kopf so klick gemacht hat und ich diesen
neuen Skill einfach gelernt habe und das
ist halt so eine krasse Erfahrung
einfach für mich gewesen weil ich bis
jetzt mich eigentlich immer vor
unangenehmen Situationen gedrückt habe
was ich auch völlig okay finde also ich
habe mich dafür jetzt nie gejudged oder
fand ich war jetzt schwach oder so das
will ich damit hier jetzt gar nicht
sagen sondern eher das ja das das war
einfach so mein Wesen und das mal zur
Seite zu packen und zu sagen hey ich
traue mich jetzt ich überwinde diese
Angst also ich hatte wirklich Angst um
mein Leben gestern schon paar mal und
heute halt teilweise auf diesem hohen
Berg dann auch und es ist ja nicht so
also ja man hat schon echt Angst also
ich habe schon extrem Angst und sich
dann die ganze zu überwinden
geisteskrank einfach nur geisteskrank ja
und dann hat's aber auch gut
funktioniert und ich hö ganze Zeit nur
von hinten Timo schreien ja Vanessa du
machst jetzt schon das und jawohl
cool so alle alle GoPro Aufnahmen weil
er hält manchmal beim fahern so die
GoPro alle GoPro Aufnahmen sind wirklich
nur
so
super stark weiter schon gutes Gefühl
auch wenn der Partner stolz auf ein ist
also ich brauche das natürlich nicht ich
brauche nur mich und ich bin self
independent aber wenn Timo stolz auf
mich ist dann ist das schon extrem cool
so ja und ich ma das ja aber auch alles
hier so halb für ihn deswegen freue ich
mich dass es dass er es anerkennt und es
er sich freut aber für ihn er hat gerade
die beste Zeit seines Lebens hier ja und
das war das war so heute der Tag wir
drehen also ah und wir bleiben hier ich
hatte ja vor paar Tagen gesagt dass wir
überlegen hier zu bleiben aber ich muss
noch mal dazu sagen also ich wäre gerne
nach Basel gefahren ich habe auch in den
Kommentaren gesehen da wurde ein
bisschen disk ert da drüber ob sich
Basel lohnt oder nicht und ja wir sind
hier halt im Winter Wonderland mit
Skifahren und Kamin im Hintergrund und
was weiß ich nicht alles aber Basel war
trotzdem ein ein also hatte ich mich
drauf
gefreut es regnet halt aber nur drei
also es regnet drei Tage durch in Basel
und ganz ehrlich unser Plan für Basel
war einerseits unser Hotel zu zeigen wir
hatten nämlich ein richtig krasses Hotel
gebucht also das war das teuerste Hotel
was ich auf der Reise gebucht habe und
zwar heißt es lrois rois also die Drei
Könige auf Französisch weiß jetzt auch
nicht aus dem FF das habe ich dann
gegoogelt und das ist halt irgendwie das
älteste Grand Hotel Europas und ich
dachte halt das ist ein super cooler
Titel für so ein Vlog wir sind im
ältesten Hotel und dann wollten wir noch
auf den Weihnachtsmarkt in Basel was
offiziell der schönste Weihnachtsmarkt
Europas sein sollte und ich dachte in
meiner Planung dass das so eine perfekte
Abrundung von der ganzen Geschichte ist
und dann sind wir wieder zu Hause aber
bei Regen bei sicherem Regen im
Weihnachtsmarkt das will ich Timo nicht
antun einerseits mit der Kamera die
ganze Zeit halt mit nassen kalten Händen
so eine Kamera halten und mir selber
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht wenn ich dann
da die ganze Zeit irgendwas erzählen
möchte oder was ausprobieren möchte oder
was zeigen möchte das macht einfach
nicht so viel Spaß und deswegen haben
wir uns dann entschieden die Buchung die
zum Glück zum Stund also die die ging zu
stunniieren weil dieses Hotel auch
einfach so krass teuer war dieses TEU
dieses älteste Hotel kostete einfach
1100 Franken die Nacht für uns beide
1100 Franken und da hatten wir zwei
Nächte gebucht um alles halt in Ruhe
filmen zu können und das wären dann halt
so 2200
Franken aber ich fand's halt so cool ich
fand es halt richtig cool und wollte das
halt auch unbedingt sehen auch
geschichtlich und so und ich dachte e zu
vlogmaszeiten man kann ja auch viel von
der Steuer absetzen das müsst ihr auch
immer noch sehen ne wenn wenn wir euch
krasse Hotels oder sowas zeigen oder wo
wir so was wir so machen vieles was ich
für diese Videos auch tue weil das ja
natürlich auch irgendwo Content ist den
wir auch planen ich habe ja diese Reise
auch für vlogmas ein bisschen geplant
das ist ja alles von der steuerabsetzbau
und so und deswegen ist es immer für
mich im Kopf dann nicht ganz so teuer
wie das was ich dann bezahlen muss weil
ich ja dann was bei den Steuern spare so
funktionieren steuern aber aufgepasst
ich bin nicht Pleite ich finde das so
lustig dass zurzeit so viele oder
Youtuber Youtuber ganz besonders
Youtuber Pleite werden jetzt apped
Tanzverbot Kuchen war es ja auch
irgendwie also das ist voll das Thema
und Apate hat ja Teil oder musste jetzt
irgendwie 3,6 Millionen Steuern
nachzahlen bei 3,6 Millionen steuern
muss er irgendwas um die 7 8 Millionen
erstmal verdient haben ich habe so viel
nicht verdient nicht in 10 Jahren
Youtube das kann ich schon mal sagen und
ich bin echt gut mit meinem Geld
umgegangen ich habe habe nie das Geld
was ich gekriegt habe so richtig als
meins angesehen ich habe da viel
angespart zur Seite gelegt und bei mir
kommen auch richtig hohe Summen wenn ich
Steuern zahlen muss oder die Steuern
vorauszahlen muss aber ich habe ich habe
halt das Geld gespart ich lebe halt
nicht auf größerem Fuß als ich sollte
sage ich gerade vor m Kamin in der
Schweiz in meinem Skiurlaub wo ein
Abendessen in unserem Hotel
100 bis 150 € kostet
aber ich lebe nicht auf großem
Fuß ja ja und das ist gerade so unsere
Zeit hier also ich bin richtig froh dass
wir diese Tour gemacht haben ich hätte
es mir nicht so anstrengend vorgestellt
aber am Ende ja hätte ich mir auch
irgendwie denken können und ich freue
mich aber auch noch wieder zurück in
Berlin zu sein ich freue mich nicht auf
die Luft ich glaube wir haben hier so
viel frische Luft gerochen wie lange
schon nicht mehr aber ich freue mich auf
das was wir noch geplant haben das was
noch vor uns
kommt wir haben einiges vor und es geht
auch mit unserer Wohnung ein bisschen
weiter irgendwann werden wir mal
umziehen mal
gucken ja und das ist es uh und apropos
Preise und so morgen legen wir offen was
hier ein Tag in der Schweiz kostet wir
haben schon heute ein bisschen was
aufgenommen so und morgen ja morgen für
Euch kommt dann der Vlog das ist ich
habe ein bisschen Angst davor
weil ich habe ja alles immer so ein
bisschen gebucht oder dann essen wir
dort oder dann trinken wir da was und
man sieht ja die Preise und das ist
schon alles teuer aber das wirklich mal
alles zusammen zurechnen was hier uns
faktisch einen Tag kostet es ist
natürlich auch noch mal ein Vergleich
der nicht also auf alle zu beziehen ist
also Schweiz ist nicht gleich Schweiz
wir sind hier in einem vier stne Hotel
und das ist natürlich noch mal was
anderes als wenn man in einem Dreisterne
Hotel ist oder sogar ein Airbnb oder so
ja aber darauf freue ich mich ja und
dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder wir
genießen heute den Abend ich denke mal
ich packe gleich das Bärenfell aus und
dann wird hier auf
dem dann wird hier ähm memory gespielt
Karten gespielt ich habe noch meinen
Adventskalender mit meinen
Kreuzworträtseln dazu bin ich auch noch
nicht so richtig gekommen und wir sehen
uns
morgen tschüss Haut doch
rein